bonjour à tous La séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion après engagement de la
procédure accélérée du projet de loi
adopté par le Sénat pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration la parole est à Monsieur
géraldanin ministre de l'Intérieur et
des
res
merci
Monsieur merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chè Sabrina monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les
députés l'imigration est une des grandes
questions de notre temps elle concerne
tous les continents elle concerne tous
les pays et elle concerne tous les
peuples si l'essentiel les mouvement des
femmes et des hommes à travers le monde
concerne avant tout les pays du Sud les
pays du Sud de la planète touché par les
guerres
touché par les désolations
économiques touché par l'islamisme
radical touché par les questions
climatique nul ne peut ignorer que
l'Europe en général et la France en
particulier connaî une pression
migratoire
constante la souveraineté d'un peuple
réside aussi dans sa capacité à fixer
des
règles des règles pour savoir qui il
veut
accueillir dans quelle proportion
d'immigration la société accepte de les
accueillir et dans quelles
conditions nous pouvons assurer
l'indispensable exigence
d'intégration mesdames et messieurs les
députés débattre et légiférer sur
l'intégration et l'immigration c'est
répondre à la demande forte légitime et
répété de nos
concitoyens tous ici nous le voyons et
quel que soit ce que pense français du
sujet la maîtrise des flux
migratoires la difficulté de lutter
contre l'immigration
irrégulière l'accroissement des moyens
donnés aux préfets aux agents de
préfecture aux magistrats aux forces de
l'ordre est un débat essentiel est un
débat nécessaire est un débat que
personne ne peut raisonnablement rejeté
d'un revers de la main sans que
l'Assemblée nationale ait pu en discuter
au moins quelques
instants
la distance de plus en plus forte entre
nos concitoyens et leurs responsables
politique réside dans deux
choses d'abord le fait que les
politiques et leurs institutions ne
parlent pas assez des sujets qui les
intéressent ne pas parler d'immigration
aujourd'hui refuser le débat c'est
refuser ce que demandent les
Français
la deuxième demande de nos concitoyens
c'est que les débats ne ne doivent pas
être dans les arrière-cours dans les
bureaux
politiques dans le clair obscur des
réunions de cabinets ou de partis mais
nourr et transparent devant les
représentants du
peuple refusez de
débattre refuser de débattre de
l'immigration donc refuser de parler des
sujets qui intéressent les
Français refuser de débattre de
l'immigration c'est laisser les forces
de l'ordre les agents de
préfecture tous les agents de l' avec
les graves dysfonctionnement actuels il
y a beaucoup de déclarations d'amour un
peu de preuve d'amour pour nos policiers
pour nos
gendarmesuser de débattre de
l'immigration inverse de tous nos
voisins européens qui ont tous délibéré
qui ont tous légiféré pour adopter des
règles nouvelles devant les
circonstances du
monde refuser de débattre de
l'immigration c'est ironie du
sort être moins en phase avec l'opinion
et ses demandes que la propre Union
européenne qui vient d'engager pour la
première fois un changement radical et
complet de ces règles en matière
d'immigration grâce aux engagements de
la présidence fr sous la présidence du
Président de la République fichier
Eurodac qui va permettre pour la
première fois d'enregistrer tous les
étrangers arrivant sur le sol européen
asile à la frontière de l'Europe
conditionnement des visas avec la
politique migratoire de l'Union
européenne la France mesdames et
messieurs les députés ne peut pas être
le seul pays d'Europe ne peut pas être
le seul pays d'Europe à ne pas vouloir
débattre d'un sujet essentiel de
souveraineté d'humanité et d'avenir
je suis sûr que l'Assemblée nationale
comme dans tous les grands moments de
son
action aura conscience d'elle-même et
saura être fidèle à sa mission
représenter notre peuple et débattre de
tous les sujets pour le bien de
l'intérêt
général qui a peur du débat en tout cas
pas la majorité
présidentielle qui a peur du débat ceux
qui vont dans une alliance contre nature
se mettre d'accord pour que les Français
ne voi pas les Ch ch avancé et pour
désarmer nos policiers et nos
gendarmes après les avancées européennes
que j'ai évoqué le gouvernement après le
travail du Conseil d'État appels travail
de la commission des Lois du Sénat après
le Sénat après la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée national présente un projet
de loi de 27 articles et de 47 articles
rajoutés par le Sénat et par la
commission des
lois cela veut-elle dire que le texte
est figé et que le débat est terminé non
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
gouvernement ne fait que commencer le
débat avec
vous le gouvernement est disposé à
étudier minutieusement les 2600
amendements déposés
parlementaire les parlementaires qui
ayant déposé autant d'amendements ont
envie à mon avis de débattre sinon à
quoi sert-il de déposer 2600 amendements
sans que personne n'est à les
connaître nous rentrons ici avec la
conviction que des compromis doivent
être faits pour l'intérêt général pour
la protection des Français pour la
protection de nos frontières pour
l'intégration des étrangers pour la
lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière ce texte vous le savez
présente trois grands axes une
simplification drastique des procédures
aujourd'hui nous mettons trop de temps à
répondre si c'est oui ou si c'est non
pour les étrangers qui arrivent sur
notre sol plus de 2 ans en moyenne quand
le texte inspiré directement du rapport
du sénateur buffet prévoit la division
par trois des recours et permettra de
moins en moins de 8 mois de répondre
nous ne sommes pas laxistes mais nous
mettons trop de temps à répondre et là
où tous les pays autour de nous ont été
au rendez-vous de la rapidité la
rapidité de l'administration la rapidité
de la justice nous devons absolument
prendre des mesures de simplification
c'est l'objet de trois titres entiers de
ce projet de
loi la lutte contre les étrangers
délinquants comment peut-on réclamer de
la fermeté et refuser au policiers
gendarmes au préfet les moyens
d'expulser les étrangers délinquants
comment peut-on faire la une des
journaux aller sur les plateaux de
télévision tenir des meetings quand le
gouvernement et la majorité arrivent
avec des dispositions pour les lui
refuser et finalement désarmer les
policiers et les
gendarmes comment peut-on siamment
s'opposer à des dispositions qui vont
nous permettre d'expulser ou d'éloigner
4000 étrangers délinquants que ni la
Constitution ni la Convention européenne
des Droits de l'omme ni l'Europe nous
empêche de le faire c'est la loi de la
République qui le permet c'est la loi de
la République qu'il faut
changer enfin
l'intégration il n'y a pas de politique
d'immigration qui vaille sans une
intégration forte exigeante et beaucoup
d'utreenus ont connu des parents des
grandspents parfois des députés
eux-mêmes issus de cette immigration qui
attend si fort de l'intégration de la
langue de la République du travail du
bien logement et finalement de
l'acceptation d'une société nous ne
sommes pas assez fermes nous ne donnons
pas assez de moyens ce texte de loi
répond à la grande exigence de
l'intégration je salue le travail des
sénateurs et des commissaires aux lois
de l'Assemblée
nationale s'il écarte des sujets sil
écarte des sujets qui clairement n'ont
pas leur place dans ce texte car le
Conseil constitutionnel à coup sûr
censura et s'ils sont censurés alors
nous allions mentir aux Français en
portant des débats qui n'auraient pas
lieu d'être le gouvernement
s'engage dans les tout prochains temps
dès le début de l'année 2024 à répondre
aux exigences et aux questions posées
par les sénateurs comme une évaluation
et une réforme de l'aide médicale
d'État nous venons d'écrire avec le
ministre de la Santé et des solit et
solidarité ce matin au président des
groupes de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat pour nous engager clairement dans
cette voie et annoncer le dépôt de texte
qui permettent la réforme de cette ame
directement
inspiré directement inspiré par le
rapport de Monsieur stéphanini et de
Monsieur
evvin ce texte immigration beaucoup le
commentent à
l'extérieur et j'avoue comme beaucoup
d'entre vous ne pas toujours reconnaître
ce qui est écrit dedans
lorsqu'on lit le texte immigration
disponible par chacune et par chacun sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale on peut
se demander comment peut-on s'opposer à
la réussite obligatoire d'un examen de
français pour avoir un titre de séjour
long en France 400000 étrangers
concernés comment peut-on êtreosé opposé
au cours gratuit à cmfs étrangers pour
permettre l'intégration et pendant leurs
heur de travail comment peut-on s'ooser
au moyens et pouvoirs considérabl donné
à nos forces de l'ordre à nos préfets à
nos magistrats comment peut-on s'opposer
à l'inspection des véhicules aux
frontières demandés par les policiers
par les gendarmes depuis plus de 40 ans
comment peut-on s'opposer à la prise
d'empreinte obligatoire pour reconnaître
l'identité des personnes et savoir
vraiment qui est majeur et qui est
mineur et de quelle nationalité il est
comment peut-on s'opposer à la
simplification drastique de notre droit
voter mesdames et messieurs les députés
à l'unanimité des sénateurs du rapport
François Noël buffet et qui divise par
trois les recours et ainsi permettra
d'améliorer évidemment les reconduites à
la frontière comment peut-on s'opposer
au retitre au retrait des titres de
séjour pour tous ceux qui adhèrent à
l'islamisme radical et qui ne respectent
pas les valeurs de la République comment
peut-on s'opposer à ne plus mettre des
enfants de 3 ans ou de 5 ans dans des
centres de rétention administratif afin
qu'ils puissent se construire
psychologiquement en dehors des
traumatismes d'aujourd'hui comment
peut-on s'opposer à la dureté demandée
par le gouvernement contre les passeurs
ces marchant de mort responsable des
noyades en Méditerranée et en manch
aujourd'hui condamné d'un simple délit
alors que demain et je remercie le garde
des sut ils seront passibles d'une peine
de 20 ans de prison en passant de délit
en crime com non peut-on refuser les
marchands de sommeil et leur macabre
commerce ceux qui logent dans des
conditions indignes et insalubres et
comme vous j'ai été maire avoir vu des
enfants des handicapés des vieillards
des personnes vulnérables qui sont
exploités par des personnes sans
scrupulle et qui sont responsables de
l'immigration irrégulière comment
peut-on refuser pour la première fois la
prise en compte de la dans la
coopération migratoire de notre
politique de visa et laisser passer
consulaire comment peut-on refuser les
dispositions qui permettront plus à la
justice et notamment au juges des
libertés de la détention de libérer un
étranger dangereux d'un cras pour simple
nulité de procédure d'un policier
comment peut-on ne pas vouloir protéger
les Français et leur sécurité en
permettant l'éloignement et l'expulsion
des étrangers délinquants qui ne peuvent
pas être expulsés du territoire national
par simple loi de la République comment
peut-on raisonnablement ne pas vouloir
en débattre comment peut-on refuser ces
armes au policiers aus gendarmes comment
peut-on sans faire la politique du pire
refuser cette
discussion bien sûr ce texte mérite
d'être amélioré et la
du gouvernement étendu dans l'intérêt
général de tous les
Français j'ai dit publiquement quels ét
les
discussions possibl avec le gouvernement
le déit de séjour irrégulier le débat
obligatoire chaque année au Parlement le
renforcement de la menace contre l'ordre
public et un meilleur
encadrement qu'on appelle de la
régularisation de l'article 4 b hier 3
qui permettra j'en suis sûr d'éviter et
de certifier de lutter contre tout appel
d'air la régularisation je veux le dire
a ici été adopté dans son principe par
le Sénat rapprochons-nous de lui bien
sûr ce texte n'empêche en aucun cas les
réformes constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles mais mesdames et
messieurs les députés il est une avancée
considérable pour les français pour
l'intérêt général pour leur sécurité et
pour les étrangers eux-mêmes il améliore
tout ce que la loi ordinaire peut
améliorer dans notre cadre
constitutionnel
actuel la politique c'est toujours un
idéal à travers des réalités chacun a
son idéal mais la réalité des Français
est la même pour toutes et tous
montronsleur que nous sommes une grande
démocratie
montrôleur que nous sommes capables de
voir dans les femmes les enfants les
hommes qui sont la manifestation te de
l'immigration et humaine de celle-ci
tout en les respectant que nous avons
compris leur demande urgente de fermeté
d'exigigen d'intégration de moyens pour
nos policiers et nos gendarmes de moyens
pour nos magistrats de moyens pour nos
préfets et de respect de nos frontières
laissons l'crimonie de côté et
montrons-nous capable comme toutes les
grandes démocraties qui se respectent de
débattre d'afficher des désaccords et de
trouver en tant de commune en respectant
les oppositions pour faire de la France
la plus beau pays du monde celui qui
fait face au grand défi de notre temps
en s'écoutant et surtout en ayant trouvé
l'un et l'autre le sens des
responsabilités mesdames et messieurs
les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés le gouvernement est prêt prêt à
débattre prêt à amender prêt à discuter
prêt à la fermeté et prêt à l'écoute il
a pris ses responsabilités j'imagine
bien ici que chacun prendra les
siennes je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Florent bouier rapporteur
général de la commission des lois
constitutionnel de la législation et de
l'administration générale de la
République madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame messieurs les
corapporteurs mes chers collègues 110
millions c'est le nombre de de déplacés
dans le monde selon le Haut Commissariat
des Nations Unies pour les
réfugiés des peuples fuit la misère ou
la guerre et il fuit d'abord vers les
pays du Sud mais les troubles au Sahel
en Libye au moyen et proche- Orient
l'instabilité dans les pays du caucas
ont des conséquences directes en Europe
un peu de silence sil vous plaî concerne
tous les pays tous les gouvernements
débattre de l'immigration c'est d'abord
parler d'enfants de femmes et d'hommes
qui cherchent un avenir
meilleur débattre de l'immigration c'est
aussi parler de la République celle qui
accueille et c'est un devoir s'agissant
de l'asile celle qui fixe souverainement
des règles avec nos partenaires
européens dans le cadre de l'État de
droit et la majorité a agi avec
constance avec la loi du 10 septembre
2018 nous avons amélioré la chaîne de
l'asile s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues un peu de silence lorsque vous
quittez l'hémicycle pour qu'on puisse
écouter le rapporteur général merci
beaucoup et nous avons agi avec la loi
du 10 septembre 2018 en améliorant la
chaîne de la et tout au long de la
période nous avons enersé nos
engossements budgétaires dans le domaine
de l'immigration de l'asile et de
l'intégration mais les migration ne sont
pas figés et il faut continuer d'agir
avec un but simple être accueillant
envers ceux qui manifestent leur volonté
de s'intégrer mieux les accompagner et
être ferme peut-être plus ferme que
jamais face à ceux qui ne respectent pas
nos règles et qui menace parfois l'ordre
public nous avons examiné les
propositions adoptées par le Sénat avec
exigence et la commission des lois a
d'ailleurs gardé des dispositifs centux
je veux le souligner je pense à
l'encadrement du titre de séjour
étranger malade je pense au renforcement
du caractère réel et sérieux de la
poursuite des études pour le titre des
séjours étudiants je pense à la fin de
l'obligation pour les autorités
organisatries de transport d'accorder
une tarification sociale à l'ensemble
des ressortissant en situation
irrégulière je pense à la grande réforme
portée par le président de la commission
des Lois du Sénat de l'instruction à
360°r des demandes de titre de séjour je
pense aussi à l'obligation de
moyens pour l'apprentissage du français
dès le pays d'origine pour les
prétendants au regroupement familial des
points de convergence donc et ils sont
très significatif et parmi eux figure la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier le Sénat a validé la nécessité
limité dans le temps ciblé sur les
métiers en tension d'une politique de
régularisation et l'article 4 bis tel
que retravaillé par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale a fait
l'objet d'un ajustement nécessaire pas
d'une distorsion mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre il est vrai que
demeure des désaccords avec le Sénat
fallait-il faire du projet de loi la
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État je ne
le crois pas d'abord parce que le
Conseil constitutionnel vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre ce serait
évidemment opposé à ce colossal cavalier
législatif ensuite parce que l'ame
relève au fond très peu du champ
régalien beaucoup du débat budgétaire et
plus encore de la santé publique mais
nous ne fermons pas la porte à la
discussion le rapport rendu la semaine
dernière par Claude evvin et Patrick
stéphanini devra s'inscrire dans un
calendrier que le gouvernement précisera
fallait-il faire du projet de loi celui
de l'accès à la nationalité mais qui
peut croire mes chers collègues que nous
pouvons valablement débattre de ce qui
fait nation de ce qui fait rien moins
que communauté nationale au détour de qu
ou C articles adoptés parfois dutamment
par le Sénat la question de la
nationalité doit bien sûr faire l'objet
d'un débat beaucoup plus sérieux
s'agissant enfin du renforcement du
Parlement en matière de politique
migratoire la commission des lois n'a
pas retenu la proposition d'objectif
plafond dont la constitutionnalité n'est
évidemment pas garantie mais le
gouvernement présentera chaque année au
Parlement ses orientations
pluréannuelles en matière migratoire et
ses objectifs chiffrés là encore nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre ces
défis que je viens de retracer à très
grand trait faut-il dans quelques
instants les écarter d'un revers de main
j'allais dire d'un revers de motion de
rejet motion de rejet qui n'aurait
d'autre conséquen que de taire le débat
que de cacher le débat et d'abord de le
cacher en direction des Français il a
raison et quand dirit nos concitoyens si
des forces politiques qui n'ont parfois
rien en commun qui n'ont pas même la
même conception jusqu'à la République
elle-même qui ne voi pas laavenir notre
pays de la même façon devait se liguer
façon contreat pour refuser le débat
c'est-à-dire pour ind dédit démocratie
moi je pense au contraire mes chers
collègues que nous sommes là pour
parlementer nous sommes là pour assumer
ce que les Français nous ont demandé de
faire faire la loi débattre et j'espère
que nous le ferons au cours des de
dernières semaines merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur
général la parole est à présent à Madame
ellodie jaquier Laforge rapporteur de la
commission des lois constitutionn de la
législation et l'administration générale
de la
République
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général messieurs les
rapporteurs mon intervention liminaire
portera sur les deux leviers principaux
qui visent à faciliter l'intégration des
immigrés le travail et l'apprentissage
de la langue française tout abord
l'accès au marché du travail qui est non
seulement un moyen de gagner sa vie mais
aussi un vecteur d'intégration sociale
et culturelle le travail permet de se
construire une vie stable en France de
tisser des liens et de mieux comprendre
les normes et les valeurs de la société
française tout en contribuant activement
à l'économie de notre pays la maîtrise
de la langue française est la meilleure
garantie de la volonté de s'intégrer de
participer à la construction d'un pays
avec son mode de vie elle permet l'accès
à éducation et à la formation et à la
bonne adéquation des compétences
professionnelles des étrangers avec le
marché de
l'emploi sans la connaissance de la
langue les barrières à l'intégration ne
tomberont pas et les répercussions sur
la vie professionnelle et personnel de
ces personnes demeureront
douloureuses voilà rapidement résumé le
constat qui préside aux ambitions du
titre premier du projet de loi dont
l'objectif est d'assurer une meilleure
intégration des étrangers par le travail
et et par la langue avant son passage au
Sénat ce titre comprenait initialement
trois chapitres le premier consacré à la
langue conditionner la première
délivrance d'une carte de séjour
pluriannuelle à la maîtrise d'un niveau
minimal de français déterminé par décret
en Conseil d'État il prévoy également la
contribution des employeurs à la
formation linguistique des travailleurs
étrangers
hophones le second consacré au travail
portait plusieurs disposition innovante
et ambitieuse je pense notamment à la
création à titre expérimental d'une
carte de séjour temporaire portant la
mention travailleurs des métiers en
tension à l'accélération de l'accès au
marché du travail des demandeurs d'asile
ressortissant de pays pour lesquels un
taux de protection internationale élevé
est généralement accordé et la refonte
de dispositions juridiques relatives au
Passeport talent et au titrre qui
concernent les praticiens de son
à diplôme hors Union Européenne les
dénommés
Pasu enfin le dernier chapitre visait à
mieux protéger les étrangers contre les
employeurs abusifs comprenant une unique
disposition portant la création d'une
nouvelle amende administrative
sanctionnant les employeurs d'étrangers
ne détenant pas un titre les autorisant
à travailler vous le savez mes chers
collègues le Sénat a largement modifié
ce titre s'agissant du chapitre premier
il a en particulier renforcé les
conditions d'intégration posées dans le
cadre du contrat d'intégration
républicaine nous avons pour une bonne
part conservver ses ajouts le Sénat a
par ailleurs souhaité intégrer plusieurs
dispositions relatives au droits de la
nationalité que la commission des lois
de notre Assemblée a souhaité supprimer
si nous partageons l'intention des
sénateurs d'avoir une discussion sur ce
sujet important le projet de loi qui
nous est soumis aujourd'hui n'est pas le
véhicule législatif adéquate pour
parvenir en matière de travail le Sénat
a adopté une version plus opérationnelle
de l'article 8 relatif au sanction
administratives contre les employeurs
d'étrangers sans
titre il a par ailleurs réduit la portée
de plusieurs
dispositifs c'est pourquoi nous avons en
commission des lois notamment rétabli la
disposition relative à l'accès de
certains demandeurs d'asile au marché du
travail que le Sénat avait supprimé et
une partie substantielle de celle qui
concerne les
pasadu ce volet a enfin été l'occasion
et j'imagine que cela n'aura échappé à
personne de débattre du dispositif
d'accès au séjours pour les étrangers
exerçant dans les métiers en tenstion
que le Sénat a conservé mais qui l'a
transformé en un dispositif à titre
exceptionnel et
discrétionnaire je me réjoui que nous
ayons abouti en commission des lois à un
dispositif
équilibré qui n'aboutit ni à un droit
automatique à la régularisation ni une
procédure discrétionnaire à la seule
main du préfet nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir dans cet hémicycle et
pourquoi pas de l'affiner plus encore je
vous remercie infiniment mes chers
collègues pour votre
attention merci Madame la
rapporteur s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues essayez de respecter les
orateurs successifs la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe Pradal rapporteur
toujours de la commission des
lois madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général madamees
et Messieurs les corrapporteurs mes
chers collègues il m ch l'honneur de
vous présenter le résultats des travaux
de notre commission sur les titres 2 et
de bis du projet de loi qui porte sur
des sujets part particulièrement
sensible et sur lesquels nos concitoyens
attendent des avancées puisqu'il s'agit
dans le cadre du titre 2 de rendre
possible l'éloignement d'étranger
constituant une medace grave pour
l'ordre public et de mieux tirer les
conséquences des actes répréhensibles
des étrangers en matière de droit au
séjour le titre de BIS quant à lui
composé entièrement d'article issus des
discussions au Sénat comporte des
dispositions destinées à agir pour la
mise en œuvre effective des décisions
d'éloignement le titre 2 comporte des
dispositions ambitieuses qui abord des
questions sensibles et engageantes pour
l'ensemble de notre société je pense
notamment à l'article 9 qui prévoit
d'assouplir les régimes de protection
dont bénéficient certaines catégories de
ressortissants étrangers en raison des
liens d'attachement qu'ils entretiennent
avec la France cette mesure
particulièrement importante et attendu
je le sais permettra de faciliter les
décisions d'expulsion et le prononcer de
la peine d'interdiction du territoire je
me félicite du travail que nous avons
mené en commission sur ces dispositions
pour éétablir l'équilibre et la
proportionnalité de l'article 9
la rédaction de cet article tel que nous
l'examinerons parvient ainsi à concilier
l'objectif de préservation de la
sécurité et de l'ordre publicque avec
celui du respect de la vie privée et
familiale toujours dans le respect des
principes constitutionnels et
conventionnels je pense également à
l'article 10 relatif au régime de
protection contre les TF j'ai la
conviction que la rédaction venue du
Sénat est équilibrée celle-ci a en tout
cas été adopté sans modification en
Commission en matière de relevé
d'empreinte sans cons et à l'initiative
du Président marcangéi et du groupe
horizon nous avons aménagé le cadre
procédural introduit au Sénat afin de ne
pas prévoir d'obligation superféatoire
sans nuire aux garanties reconnu aux
étrangers la Commission a d'ailleurs
adopté la proposition des rapporteurs de
consigner ses opération dans un procès
verbal nous avons également procédé à la
suppression de l'article 11 relatif au
fichiier des MNA délinquants sujet
inopportun car satisfait par l'existence
d'autres fichiers en adoptant des
amendements de votre serviteur et des
groupes renaissants
démocrate LFI écologiste socialiste et
GDR je tiens aussi à souligner l'avancée
majeure à laquelle notre commission a
contribué en interdisant à l'article 12
la présence dans tous les lieux de
rétention des mineurs de tout age en
adoptant la quasi unanimité un
amendement du groupe lot cette
disposition est fondamentale et marque
un tournant dans notre appréhension de
la place des mineurs en rétention
administrative le débat que nous allons
engager nous permettra de nous assurer
que la vulnérabilité des personnes
concernées est bien prise en compte par
l'autorité administrative j'eneviens
enfin à l'important article 13 sur le
respect des principes de la République
dans lequel à mon initiative nous avons
rétabli la compétence discrétionnaire
des préfets afin de respecter les
exigences constitutionnelles et
conventionnelles objectif qui nous a
aussi conduit à supprimer le caractère
facultatif du trouble à l'ordre public
que revet la tête à ces principes les
principes de la République ont par
ailleurs été enrichis afin d'embrasser
la totalité du principe d'égalité à mon
initiative et d'inclure l'intégrité
territoriale de notre pays sur
proposition de notre collègue Estelle
yousoufa la Commission a par ailleurs
dans un nouvel article 13 B a prévu la
possibilité de refuser un visa à un
étranger qui aurait des detes non réglé
à l'égard des établissements de santé
français sur proposition du groupe
horizon nous avons également en adoptant
de nombreux abonnement supprimer les
articles 13 B et 14 g je précise pour ma
part que ces suppressions avaent
simplement pour but et objet d'inscrire
ses dispositions dans le titre 6 sur les
outres m ce qui fut fait à l'invitation
de nos collègues sénateurs qui ont
introduit un nouveau titre de BIS nous
avons travaillé sur le lien entre
coopération migratoire avec des États
étrangers aide publique au développement
et délivrance de visa à leur
ressortissant je me réjouis des avancées
permises en commission sur l'article 14a
pour parvenir à des dispositions à
nouveau équilibré et efficaces qui Assur
la cohérence entre politique public
d'aide au développement et de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière nous
poursuivrons en séance le
perfectionnement de ces dispositions
importantes par ailleurs si nous avons
fait le choix en commission de supprimer
l'article 14e je tiens à souligner que
nous avons conservé dans leur rédaction
issue des travaux du Sénat l'intégralité
des articles 14b 14d et
14f je me réjouis par avance des débats
qui je l'espère s'annonce et qui j'en
suis convaincu nous permettrons tous de
compléter utilement les travaux de notre
commission je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Ludovic mendz rapporteur de la
commission des
lois merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général madamees
et Messieurs les corrapporteurs mes
chers collègues je vais désormais vous
présenter nos travaux sur le les titres
3 à 5 du projet de loi dont j'ai
l'honneur d'être rapporteur la
Commission comme le Sénat avant elle a
pleinement approuvé les dispositions des
articles 14 et 15 qui renforcent la
lutte contre les réseaux de passeurs et
les marchands de sommeil en étoffant
utilement notre arsenal pénal je précise
et c'est important comme j'ai pu le
faire en commission que les engg
humanitaires d'aide aux migrants ne sont
pas concernés par l'article 14 et s'il
faut le répéter on le répétera autant
que possible nous avons également validé
le principe du nouvel article 15 bis
introduit au Sénat à l'initiative de Yan
brossa qui étant victimes des conditions
indignes d'hébergement les dispositions
prévoyant la délivrance d'un titre à
l'étranger victime qui porte plainte ou
témoigne contre l'auteur des fait nous
avons d'ailleurs à l'initiative de notre
président Sacha oulier étendu ce champ
aux victimes de conditions de travail
incompatible avec la dignité humaine
toujours en matière de titre pour motif
humanitair nous avons sur proposition
conjointe de madame Rousseau du
président Valot et de moi-même augmenter
la durée du titre délivré aux victimes
de proxénétisme engagé dans un parcours
de sortie de la prostitution la
Commission a également approuvé les
mesures en matière de de contrôle aux
frontières en renforçant l'efficacité
des visites sommaires de véhicules
particulier à mon initiative et nos
débats en séance devraient permettre
d'enrichir cet aspect du texte notamment
s'agissant des
navières les discussions exigeantes
menées en commission sur le titre 4
consacré à la réforme de l'asile nous
ont permis améliorer le texte sur des
questions essentielles sur l'article 19
qui crée des pôles France asile nous
sommes revenus sur l'expérimentation
voulue par le Sénat pour permettre un
déploiement immédiat de ce dispositif
mais nous avons tenu à conserver
certains éléments votés par nos
collègues
sénateurs nous avons également précisé
le déroulement de la procédure entre
l'introduction de la demande d'asile et
l'entretien personnel du demandeur avec
un officier de protection de l'OFPRA
nous poursuivrons en séance publique je
n'en doute pas le dialogue sur ces
différents points de même concernant
l'article 20 qui réforme la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile les travaux
en commission ont permis de tenir compte
de la situation particulière des
rcurrents mineurs à l'initiative de nos
collègues Philippe brin et Arwen balanan
j'ai souhaité au travers de plusieurs
amendements qui ont été adoptés par la
commission modifier l'article 21 relatif
à la simplification du contentieux
administratif des étrangers pour
parvenir au travers d'une architecture
organisé autour de quatre procédures à
concilier l'impératif de simplification
de ce contentieux avec celui de
l'efficacité de la mise en œuvre de
notre politique
d'éloignement la Commission a également
renforcé les garanties applicables pour
encadrer davantage le recours à la vidéo
audience devant le juge administratif
comme devant le juge judiciaire ces
dispositions j'en suis convaincu sont
équilibrées et offrent une réponse
adapté à l'exigence de rapidité et
d'efficacité du traitement judiciaire de
ce contentieux sans sacrifier la
protection des droits de l'étranger
justiciable je me félicite enfin du
travail de notre commission sur
l'article 25 un article de grande ance
qui tient compte de manière très
concrète de l'évolution du contentieux
des étrangers et permet d'adapter les
règles procédurales à la réalité de ce
contentieux cette disposition réécrite
par la commission tire notamment les
leçons de l'expérience du traitement
judiciaire des migrants arrivés à bord
de l'ocean Viking à Toulon en novembre
2022 et offre une réponse procédurale
adaptée pour faire face à la gestion
simultanée d'un nombre important
d'étrangers en zone
d'attente ces trois sites proposent donc
des dispositions qui me paraissent
essenti chers collègues ce débat nous
devons l'avoir nous ne pouvons plus le
repousser nous devons l'accepter tel
qu'il est car oui tous les pays tous les
régimes politiques tous les
gouvernements sont concernés par les
questions migratoires qui font partie
des deux grands défis de notre siècle
avec les questions
environnementales parler d'immigration
est certes difficile car nous parlons de
femmes d'hommes et d'enfants mais c'est
nécessaire et éminemment politique
parler d'immigration c'est aussi parler
de notre modèle répuque ain et social de
sa capacité à intégrer des moyens qu'on
lui octroit des règles que nous nous
fixons collectivement parler
d'immigration c'est également parler de
sécurité enfin parler d'immigration
c'est parler aux Français car oui les
Français soutiennent en grande majorité
le projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement et attendent de cette
assemblée que les débats soient apaisés
constructifs et utile je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier serva rapporteur de la
commission des
[Applaudissements]
lois madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames Messieurs
les corapporteurs chers collègues
députés j'ai l'honneur de clore cette
série d'interventions en tant que
rapporteur du titre 6 de la loi
consacrée aux
outremè je tiens en premier lieu à
rappeler que ma démarche tout au long
des travaux qui ont été menés au sein de
la commission des lois a été en tant que
rapporteur celle de la concertation de
la coconstruction c'est ainsi que nous
avons consulté les 11 territoires
peuplés ultramarins sur les trois
océan alors que nous nous apprêtons en
principe à légiférer ensemble dans les
jours à venir sur la situation de ce
territoire
d'outremer je veux rappeler avec force
ma conviction profonde et celle du
groupe auquel j'appartient au groupe lot
qui est qu'aucune mesure ne doit être
adoptée sans une très large adhésion des
territoires
concernés cette démarche a d'ors et déjà
permis d'enrichir considérablement le
projet de loi il faut en effet rappeler
que le titre 6 tel qui nous arrivait du
Sénat ne comportait que deux articles
c'est à notre Assemblée nationale qui
est comb la tâche de traduire dans la
loi ce qui a été l'engagement du
gouvernement de ne pas légiférer par
ordonnance pour les collectivités dere
mè régies par l'article 73 de notre
Constitution c'est-à-dire Guadeloupe
Martinique guyan Réunion Mayotte plus
Saint-Pierre et miclon les travaux de la
commission des lois ont ainsi
considérablement étaufé le titre 6 en y
introduisant des disposition sur mesure
adapté aux réalités et aspirations de
chaque territoire je veux en particulier
me réjouir de l'accord qui a été trouvé
pour permettre en outre MRE la
territorialisation de l'établissement de
la liste des métier intention celle-ci
sera définie après un avis de la
commission placée sous l'autorité du
préfet et composé de l'ensemble des
acteurs pertinents à l'échelle locale
chambre consulaire élu organisation
syndicale et patronale pour s'assurer de
la réalité du marché du travail et
qu'elle soit correctement prise cette
réalité de même dans le cadre du
mécanisme de régularisation de l'article
4 bis le préfet pourra à Saint-Pierre et
miclon lors du renouvellement du premier
titre de séjour délivrer une carte
pluriannuelle afin de tenir compte de la
situation particuliale de cet archipel
qui a un besoin pressant de ma d'œuvre à
long terme les travaux de la commission
des lois ont ainsi permis l'adoption de
mesures qui me sembleent équilibré et
qui tiennent compte de spécificité de
chaque territoire d'outrè sans
dogmatisme
à l'initiative de deux amendements
présentés par mon collègue dviman
président de la délégation zromè le
texte adopté par la Commission prévoit
explicitement l'application du schéma
national d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile au territoire d'romer ce qui
permettra de renforcer la planification
des lieux d'hébergement et d'assurer que
les moyens nécessaires sont déployés par
l'État dans les territoires ultramarins
afin d'assurer un accueil digne partout
sur le territoire de la République publ
toujours à l'initiative du président
riman la commission des lois a également
voté l'instauration d'une Commission du
titre de séjour en Guyane ce qui
permettra de renforcer les garanties
procédurales pour les étrangers auxquels
le préfet envisage de refuser le droit
de séjour de même les travaux de mes
collègues députés de Mayotte Estelle
yousoufa et Mansour camardine ont donné
lieu à l'adoption de plusieurs
dispositions qui permettront à ce
département de tenir compte d'une
situation igatoire irrégulière sans
pareil sur le territoire national je
pense par exemple à l'adoption des
mesures relatives au droit du sol ou à
la délivrance de certains titres de
séjour je souhaite que nos débats en
séance publique puissent poursuivre ce
travail mes chers collègues je me
réjouis que notre assemblée puisse en
principe débattre des dispositions du
projet de loi qui concerneront les
territoires ultramarins je souhaite que
nous gardions à l'esprit lors de nos
débats que si ce territoire justifie
pleinement ention du législateur ils ne
peuvent être abordés sous le prisme
d'une norme unique et qu'il faut se
garder d'une approche trop maniquenne
qui méconnaîtrait la réalité des autres
maires je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
sachaoulier président de la commission
des lois constitutionnelles la
législation et de l'administration
générale de la
République madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues enfin
comme en commission je le redis enfin
l'Assemblée nationale est saisie de ce
texte important pour l'avenir de notre
pays et pour l'avenir de notre société
le projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
est un texte radical un texte volontaire
il porte des ambitions de fermeté
auxquell beaucoup pendant de nombreuses
années ont renoncé nous ne renoncerons
pas il regarde en réalité en face la
réalité de l'immigration dans notre pays
et l'emploi dans de nombreux secteurs
dépourvu de salariés d'une main d'œuvre
étrangère en situation irrégulière nous
voulons mettre fin à cette hypocrisie il
accepte de nommer et surmonter les
difficultés criantes de notre
administration des juridictions du droit
d'asile et des juridictions
administratives ensevelie sous les
dossiers les recours et les procédures
nous souhaitons simplifier cette
bureaucratie mortifère expulser les
étrangers délinquants régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier simplifier nos
procédures nos objectifs sont clairs ils
n'ont jamais varié nous les n avons en
18 mois jamais perdu de vue la
commission des lois a largement adopté
ce projet de loi par 35 voix contre 16
elle a
assoupli accompli au terme de 48 heur de
débat un travail d'un sérieux
incontestable et je souhaite saluer
devant cette hémicycle ses rapporteurs
monsieur Florent bouer madame ellodie
Jaquet Laforge Monsieur Philippe Pradal
monsieur Ludovic mendz et Monsieur
Olivier
serva j'ai lu par ailleurs que notre
commission aurait dénaturé la version
élaborée par le Sénat je ne partage pas
cet
avis celui que nous avons élaboré puis
adopté expurge les cavaliers législatifs
les plus certains ce relatif au mineurs
au code de la nationalité ce relatif à
la suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
que nous avons rétabli leur sort aurait
été réglé sans le moindre doute par le
Conseil constitutionnel et de mon point
de vue le législateur s'affaiblit en en
attendant une une une censure quasi
certaine le texte que nous avons adopté
conserve un certain nombre de
dispositions sur lesquelles j'ai de
sérieux doutes et de franchesopposition
c'est aussi la loi du compromis notre
commission s'est aussi entendue sur
l'essentiel demain si le texte est voté
si l'assemblée nous laisse l'opportunité
de l'étudier ce sont 4000 étrangers
délinquants présents dans notre péis qui
pourront être reconduits en dehors de
nos frontières c'est la double peine
supprimée en 2003 qui leur sera à
nouveau opposable ce sont les excuses à
l'éloignement ou à l'expulsion qui
constitue désormais les célèbres
réserves d'ordre public qui seront
levées ce sont des titres de séjour
jours qui pourront être retirés ou qui
ne seront pas renouvelés pour non
respect des valeurs de la République
vous avez été nombreux à demander dans
cet hémicycle des moyens nouveau pour
l'État ils sont là demain si vous votez
ce texte ceux qui participent aux
filières d'immigration clandestine les
passeurs et la criminalité organisée
seront pris pour ceux qu'ils sont
réellement des criminels et non
seulement des délinquants si vous votez
ce texte l'état pourra mieux connaître
de la situation des personnes présentes
sur son territoire grâce à
l'enregistrement de leurs empreintes
mais il est tout ai vrai que si demain
ce texte est voté il n'y aura plus de
rétention des mineurs ni dans les
centres de rétention administrative ni
dans les lieux de rétention
administratifs de même que pour tenir
compte de la réalité crue que j'ai déjà
décrite nous procéderons à la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension prévu par l'article 4
bis pour laquelle j'ai accepté certains
compromis les employeurs concernés
auront de surprroix des obligations de
former leurs salariés non francophones
les demandeurs d'asile qui par leur
nationalité ont le plus de chance d'être
protégé pourront travailler et plus
seulement dépendre des ation sociale les
employeurs qui abusent de la main
d'œuvre étrangère et de sa précarité
seront sanctionnés les étrangers
victimes de conditions de travail
inhumaines de proxénétisme des marchands
de sommeil se verront protégés par la
réécriture et l'élargissement de
l'amendement bressa alors oui ce texte
comporte des avancées sociales qui
mettent un terme à l'hypocrisie
collectivement entretenue ces dernières
années il est absolument faux il est
absolument faux de dire qu'il crée un
hypothétique appel d'air ces personnes
sont déjà sur notre sol il reste que
nous débattrons peut-être des mesures
les plus essentielles celles de la
simplification des procédures il suffit
pour chacun d'entre nous de se rendre
dans un service des étrangers d'une
préfecture dans à l'OFI ou dans un
tribunal pour constater la masse de
travail et la complexité des
procédures la réduction de 12 à 3
procédures contentieuses l'examen à 360°
sont quelques exemples de ce que ce
texte permettra il reste que nous avons
pas omis de consacrer les spécificités
de no collectivités ultramarines
j'insiste pas par des ordonnances mais
dans la loi tout le titre 6 y est
consacré monsieur le ministre chers
collègues la commission des lois vous
présente un texte radical un texte
ambitieux un texte volontaire ce projet
a besoin de V suffrag mais nos
compatriotes les Françaises et les
Français ont besoin de ce projet la
majorité montrer qu'elle était prête à
des compromis mais pour faire des
compromis il faut au moins être
de beaucoup monsieur le
Président la Paro
est observation de la commission des
affaires
européennes
bien
[Musique]
monsieur le rapporteur vous êtes très
attendu
manifestement bien madame la présidente
madame monsieur le ministre madames
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues 1,6 million de nouvelles
entrées d'immigrés en France entre 2017
et 2022 soit le double de la taille de
la ville de Marseille 600 à 900000
clandestins des ambulants dans les rues
de notre pays moins de 7%
des obligations de quitter le territoire
français réellement exécuté en 2022 3,8
million de titres de séjour en
circulation fin 2022 soit 25 % de plus
en 5 ans 75 % des vols à Paris commis
par des étrangers cette 30e loi sur
l'immigration depuis 1980 n'est pas un
projet de loi comme les autres c'est
d'abord celui du bilan catastrophique de
la politique migratoire du président de
la République ou plutôt son absence de
politique migratoire laissant grandes
ouvertes
de notre pays au réseau de passeur au
violeurs voleur et assassin jeetend du
même coup le probre sur l'ensemble des
étrangers vivant dans notre pays tant
vous êtes incapable de séparer le bon
grain de livr l'intégrer de l'islamisé
le travailleur de
l'assister dans la majorité ce projet de
loi paraî donc pour les uns comme une
rédemption pour les autres comme une
tentative d'émancipation pour les
Français il devra pas être une nouvelle
déception la question voir s'il n'est
pas déjà trop tard tant vivent déjà dans
notre pays des millions de personnes
françaises ou étrangères en marche de la
République de ses valeurs de la science
de la laïcité de toute vie en société
face à face et non pas côte à côte dès
lors est-il raisonnable de vouloir
accueillir plus encore même en
renforçant légèrement les contrôles
alors que nos capacités d'intégration
sont saturées nous ne le pensons pas les
quelques avancées de ce projet de loi en
particulier la levée de certains fres à
l'expulsion sont à relever mais sont
loin faire le poid face à tout le reste
qu'il s'agisse de votre bilan ou de vos
propositions au contraire puisque vous
refusez de prendre des mesures
réellement coercitive à l'encontre des
pays qui ne veulent pas reprendre leur
clandestin en leur coupant l'aide au
développement les visas étudiants vous
arriverez au paradoxe de la dégradation
du taux d'exécution des TF puisque vous
en délivrerez plus sans pour autant
obtenir la S passés consulair nécessaire
à l'expulsion député de calé du calisi
de la ruralité terre qui fait face au
chaos migratoire de plusieurs dizaines
d'années je ne peux que constater les du
projet de loi pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des habitants de mon
territoire permettre le développement
économique des entreprises arrêter
transformer la Manche en cimetière rien
pour sanctionner les associations no
bordur et leurs membres qui organisent
les squat et incitent les migrants à
refuser les mises à l'abri organisé par
l'État laissant les malheureux dans les
mains de passeurs marchand de mort rien
pour établir le délit de séjour
irrégulier ni pour faciliter le contrôle
des véhicules particuliers rien pour
octroyer un statut particulier à mon
territoire devenu frontière extérieure
de l'Europe depuis le brexit rien pour
donner des conditions dignes de travail
aux forces de l'ordre où les policiers
de calé s'entassent dans un commissariat
obsolète et les garder à vue dans des
joles véustes le projet de loi que vous
nous présentez demeure s'il n'est pas
rectifié dans les prochains jours celui
du mépris de mon territoire et des
occasions manqué un constat clair
do-être dressé entre la majorité et nous
deux visions diamétralement opposé de
l'immigration s'affronte pour vous
l'immigré doit faire le travail que les
Français ne veulent plus faire et tant
pis s'il tirent les salaires des Médiers
les moins qualifiés vers le bas et
empêche l'amélioration des condition de
travail mettant en concurrence déloyale
le clandestin malien et la mère de
famille monoparentale de banlieu à votre
immigration familiale sousqualifié et
subi nous préférons une immigration de
travail surqualifié et choisie vous
voulez régulariser les clandestins qui
ont travaillé 8 mois dans les 2 ans dans
un métier en tension non seulement ceux
présents aujourd'hui sur le territoire
mais également ceux qui ne sont pas
encore présents en France vous voulez
rendre encore plus inexpulsabl les
demandeurs d'asile déboutés en leur
permettant de travailler dès le dépôt de
leur demande vous avez supprimé en
commission des lois la transformation de
l'Ame en aide limitée aux seules
urgences le réétablissement du délit de
séjour irrégulier et l'aménagement du
droit du sol vous refusez de dénoncer
l'accord de 68 entre la France et
l'Algérie excluant les imigrés algérien
du droit commun leur offrant un droit
migratoire dérogatoire ultra favorable
vous rejetez toute réforme de la
Constitution visant ne plus soumettre
nos tentatives d'expulsion d'étrangers
dangereux à la jurisprudence permissive
du droit européen
vous organisez l'impuissance publique
Provo la défiance générale et ce faisant
vous PZ la route du pouvoir au populisme
tant que vous emprunterez ce chemin nous
combattrons vos projets non pas parce
que vous les portez mais parce qu'ils
sont mortifères pour notre pays sa
cohésion ses habitants son essence plus
seulement à long terme mais également et
c'est bien là le bilan du macronisme à
plus court terme je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
je vous remercie s'il vous plaît un peu
de
silence j'ai reçu de Madame cyielle
châtelin et des membres du groupe
écologiste une motion de rejet préalable
déposée en application de l'article 91
alinéa 5 de notre
règlement la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin Lucas pour une durée de 15
minutes
[Applaudissements]
allez s'il vous plaît un peu de
silence madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général madamees
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
parler de la migration des hommes et des
femmes n'est pas seulement l'affaire
d'un débat législatif juridique
technique c'est aussi et peut-être même
d'abord parler nous-même de la nation
que nous formons ensemble c'est chercher
à comprendre l'idée que chacune et
chacun se fait de la France de sa place
dans le monde c'est invoquer les valeurs
qui nous dépassent une histoire qui nous
oblige c'est plonger dans l'intimité de
vies humaines qui dépendent directement
des décisions que nous prenons le hasard
au sort a amené mon groupe à présenter
cette motion de rejet je veux le dire en
préambule aux collègues de LR de Lyot
mais aussi à ceux qui dans la majorité
doutent voter le rejet dans un instant
nétant rien une adhésion à mon propos et
ne sera pas instrumentalisé comme telle
nos règles parlementaires et
démocratiques sont
claires je sais qu'il n'existe pas sur
ce sujet de majorité pouvant se
rattacher ici à l'analyse que je
formulerai dans un instant et je pas
l'outre cuidance de croire que je puisse
en quelques instants vous convaincre
mais il n'existe pas d'avantage de
majorité autour du texte du
Gouvernement et c'est bien là le seul
objet de cette motion oui ou non le
gouvernement peut-il obtenir Infiné les
voix nécessaires à l'adoption de son
projet chacune et chacun ici connaît la
réponse ce vote doit permettre d'en
apporter la démonstration nous n'en
tirerons aucune gloire et nous savons
que ce n'est pas autour de nos idées que
se fait ce SCR
nous ne le prendrons que comme un point
d'appui tournant ainsi la page de long
de très longs mois que vous avez employé
à tenter de rallier une majorité d'entre
nous monsieur le ministre voici plus
d'un an que nous discutons de ce projet
mes chers collègues il est temps de
décider monsieur le ministre vous n'avez
pas su trouver ici les équilibres et les
compromis qui vous étaient nécessaires
par conséquent la discussion
parlementaire qui s'ouvrirait si
d'aventure nous rejetions cette motion
ne serait qu'un vaste marchandage visant
à débaucher individuellement les
nombreuses très nombreuses voix qui vous
manquent et nous avons vu ce weekend
encore à quel procédé démagogiques et
fallacieux vous êtes prêt à recourir à
grand renfort des moyens de l'État à
quel chantage vous vous livré sans
vergogne via les réseaux sociaux ou dans
les médias et de nombreux collègues sur
tous les bancs peuvent en témoigner la
fébrilité monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur n'excuse pas tout on
attendait de vous le comportement d'un
ministre de la républque
pas celui d'un chroniqueur de chaîne
d'information en
continue voter cette motion de rejet
c'est seulement mais nettement
reconnaître la situation politique et
parlementaire tel qu'elle est c'est dire
que ce débat sur la France sur sa place
dans le monde sur le rapport que la
République entretient à celles et à ceux
qui la rejoignne quoi que l'on pense sur
le fond mérite mieux que vos
tergiversations que vos gesticulations
et que quelques trahison n'étant ni une
carpe ni un lapin é prenant encore moins
l'alliance des deux je ne veux pas me
dérober permettez-moi d'exposer en
sincérité quelques convictions profondes
sur le fond du débat qui s'ouvre dans
notre hémicycle et qui je l'espère se
refermera dans un instant je veux en cet
instant porter la voix de ceux qui font
battre le cœur de la France ces millions
de Français anonymes qui ne sont pas
salariés de Monsieur boloret et préfère
bien souvent la compassion à
l'interjection je pense à Alfred
épidémiologiste de renom médecin
volontaire à Briançon et Montgenèvre je
pense à Chantal qui enseigne le français
à des jeunes arrivants à Avignon je
pense à Stéphane boulanger de Besançon
qui a fait la grff de la fin pour exp
pour empêcher l'expulsion de son
apprenti je pense à Fatia qui collecte
des denrées alimentaires à calé pour ces
milliers de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
qui croupissent dans la boue et le froid
je pense à Gérard de P villeneu dans le
puit d'Ô 670 habitants qui hébergent
depuis 2015 et exilés dans le dortoir
d'une ancienne colonie de vacances je
pense à Emma étudiante àre qui assure
des permanences d'accès au droit pour
les exilés je veux dire à ces milliers à
ces millions de femmes et d'hommes qui
ont confiance dans nos valeurs qui
s'inscrivent dans l'histoire de
l'humanisme qu'ils sont l'honneur et la
grandeur de la nation nous sommes la
France généreuse fraternelle
républicaine
Ernest trenant écrivait que ce qui
constitue une nation ce n'est pas de
parler la même langue ou d'appartenir à
un groupe ethnographique commun c'est
d'avoir fait ensemble de grandes choses
dans le passé et de vouloir en faire
encore dans l'avenir alors je dis pour
ma part pour ma part que nous sommes une
nation bien plus grande bien plus forte
bien plus belle que l'idée que s'en font
les partisans du repli identitaire et
nationaliste nous ne sommes qu'au début
de la grande aventure qui est la
France on nous dit minoritaire je ne
crois pas que ce soit une vérité ou tout
du moins pas une fatalité il est vrai
que nous sommes dans un moment singulier
où l'angoisse du déclassement et la
vision du déclin de la France suscite la
colère légitime de nos concitoyens il
pèse sur le débat démocratique un climat
de
peur la peur c'est l'ennemi intime de la
démocratie parce qu'elle préfigure
l'obéissance aveugle et le déferlement
de la violence alors certains agitent
ses peurs et cherchent à à désigner un
ennemi coupable de tout cet ennemi c'est
l'étranger réel ou supposé d'ailleurs à
force d'engloutir le débat public sous
les thèmes et les termes de l'extrême
droite nous avons collectivement laissé
s'installer dans notre pays un racisme
d'atmosphère ce racisme d'atmosphère se
manifeste dans les petites humiliations
du quotidien de discours stigmatisants
en amalgames orduriers de violenceces
symbolique qui deviennne physique nous
l'avons vu encore récemment ce racisme
d'atmosphère imprègne évidemment le
débat sur
l'immigration alors assez naturellement
l'opinion publique dans notre pays
surestime de 15 points le poids de
l'immigration en
France on a fait des victimes qui fuit
la guerre ou la misère des coupables
bouémissaire facile d'une France
déclassé par des décennies de
néolibéralisme fracturé par les
inégalités miné par les injustices
déserté par les services public trop
souvent impuissante face au désordr du
monde notamment devant le péril
climatique
s'il y a un grand remplacement ce n'est
pas celui auquel se réfèrent les
complotistes xénophobes c'est le grand
remplacement des agents du service
public par des machines froides et
privatisées le grand remplacement des
commerces de proximité par des entrepôts
géants de multinational le grand
remplacement de la liberté par les
discriminations de l'égalité par le
marche ou crève de la fraternité par le
chacun pour
soi
chersègues à la refondation de notre
pacte républicain à la redéfinition de
notre contrat social qu'il conviendrait
de nous atteler ici pour réparer et
apaiser le pays mais vous avez choisi
monsieur le ministre de vous engouffrer
dans le piège qui a déjà englouti nombre
de vos prédécesseurs avec tambours et
trompette vous nous annonciez un texte
d'équilibre tout en trouvant Madame Le
Pen tromolle et en reprenant jusqu'à ses
mots et ses slogans où est cet équilibre
en maigre compensation prétendument
humaniste aux nombreuses mesures
liberticies et brutales de votre projet
vous avez une promesse de bon sens pour
donner droit à des travailleurs sans
papiers piliers de notre économie au
bout du compte ou plutôt du décomte des
voies nous voilà avec quelques
régularisation dans quelques régions
pour quelques métiers en tension le tout
dans une période d'expérimentation qui
ne survivrait pas à la durée du
quinquena c'est mieux que rien mais
c'est presque rien par ailleurs de notre
point de vue faire des nouveaux
arrivants des variables d'ajustement
économiques selon le niveau de tension
de tel ou tel métier dans tel ou tel
territoire revient à les déshumaniser à
les privés de dignité c'est une rupture
grave dans les principes du droit du
travail on ne gouverne pas la France à
coup de formule comptable mais avec des
principes et des valeur qui nous oblige
notre point d'équilibre à nous n'est pas
compatible avec votre texte notre
exigence va vers une politique
d'humanité qui ne peut-être équidistante
d'aucune prétendue fermeté cette fameuse
fermeté parlons-en en 40 et 30 lois sur
l'immigration elle n'aura produit que
deux effets l'inflation des revenus des
passeurs qui indexent leurs tarifs sur
les difficultés à franchir nos
frontières et la hausse terrifiante du
nombre de morts en Méditerranée ou dans
les
Alpes au cours du jeune 21e siècle il
aura été construit 40000 km de mur à
travers le monde autant que la
circonférence de la planète pour quel
résultat notre exigence va vers une
politique de la fraternité qui est
constitutive de notre contrat
social si la fraternité trône au côté de
la liberté et de l'égalité dans le
tryptique de notre devise républicaine
ce n'est pas seulement pour demeurer
gravé en lettrre creuse au fronton de
nos mairies c'est pour forger notre
action pour s'incarner s'éprouver tant
dans le quotidien de chacune et de
chacun que dans les choix qui guident la
façon dont nous entendons relever les
grands défis de l'avenir notre exigence
va également vers une politique sur la
lucidité la lucidité c'est comprendre
que celui qui s'est arraché à sa terre
engageant un long chemin sans retour qui
a vécu la violence la faim la peur
parfois la torture ou le viol puis a vu
ses compagnons d'infortune flotter sous
forme de cadavre en Méditerranée avant
d'être traqué par la police dans le
froid des Alpes celui-là celle-là n'est
pas connecté à la chaîne parlementaire
pour se demander si telle disposition
législative va lui octroyer ou le privé
de tel droit de telle allocation de
telle protection l'appel d'air n'existe
pas laissons laissons les familles se
réunir les gens s'aimer les malades se
soigner et que cesse le harcèlement des
humanitaires la criminalisation de la
solidarité la lucidité c'est regarder
les chiffres la part des étrangers en
France est globalement stable depuis des
décennies nous accueillons moins que
nombre de nos voisins et bien moins que
la plupart des pays du Sud qui sont le
point d'arrivée de la majeure partie des
migrations non il ne nous a pas demandé
d'accueillir ou pas je ne sais quelle
juste part de la misère du monde la
lucidité c'est éprouvver une
incommensurable honte devant les
conditions de survie des exilés dans
notre pays l'indignité de nos réponses
sanitaires sociale humanitaire de
l'organisation consciente de l'entrave à
l'accès au droit des centres de
rétention compte fortune la France des
droits de l'homme tolère l'intolérable
et que dire de l'état du droit qui ne
voit dans le demandeur
d'asile qui ne voit pas le demandeur
d'asile pardon comme un persécuté mais
comme un potentiel tricheur la lucidité
c'est refusé l'enfermement des enfants
leur abandon ou la négation de leur
[Applaudissements]
minorité la lucidité c'est sortir la
comptabilité des étudiants étrangers des
statistiques de l'immigration et que
pour la plupart ils repartent dans leur
pays et ils font rayonner la France
qu'ils réussissent mieux leurs études et
rapportent 1,35 milliard d'euros chaque
année à notre économie soyons fiers pour
notre influence notre recherche notre
modèle universitaire d'accueillir tous
ces
talents la lucidité c'est comprendre que
l'intégration ne peut se résumer à une
injonction elle est un processus de
socialisation qui implique une
progression dans le temps c'est l'action
politique qui peut créer les conditions
de C inclusion en levant les obstacles
économiques sociaux éducatifs
linguistiques culturels et civiques vous
êtes dans une impass monsieur le
ministre vous ne vous y êtes pas mis
seul cet impasse vient en réalité des
premisses du
macronisme avoir cru ou fin de croire
que l'on pouvait durablement effacer de
siècles d'un clivage qui a établi
construit structurer la République entre
gauche et droite était une erreur
politique et une faute démocratique
il ne suffit pas d'agréger les renéades
et de
pour il ne suffit pas d'agréger les
renégades et de camp pour bâtir un
nouveau monde parce que ces cvages
correspondent à des visions de la
société de l'intérêt général de l'avenir
du pays ils sont respectables
l'opportunisme ne peut pas ne peut pas
être érigé en méthode de
gouvernement pour aussi beau et grand
que la France il faut une boussole qui
donne un cap quel est le vôtre sur ce
texte vous avez dit gentil avec les
gentils méchant avec les méchants mais
Monsieur le Ministre on ne gouverne pas
la France avec des slogans de cours
d'école les Français ne sont pas des
enfants pas plus que les
parlementaires quelle est votre boussole
sur un sujet aussi essentiel et clivant
parmi nous que l'aide médicale d'État
votre majorité a voté son rétablissement
en commission au Palais Bourbon après
que vous ayez donné votre blancin à sa
suppression au Palais du Luxembourg le
en même temps macroniste est donc aussi
dangereux pour la santé physique qu'il
est pour la santé démocratique il est
temps de nous en
vacciner vous avez perdu vos repères
vous avez renoncé à assumer une
conviction sans pour autant en
rencontrer d'autres ni à gauche ni à
droite de cet
hémicycle je constate que la somme des
soutiens de ce texte est inf rie à la
somme des opposants dans cette assemblée
cette réalité est la seule qui compte en
cet instant mes chers collègu rejetons
ce mauvais texte
maintenant un débat aussi important que
celui-ci sans doute parmi les
controverses les plus importantes
politiquement et moralement de notre
époque mérite mieux qu'un petit texte
porté par une petite
majorité merci beaucoup monsieur le
député
je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outremèes
merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Lucas je vous ai
entendu
et vous évoquez vos clin d'œil mais j'ai
bien vu vos clin d'œil pour
rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national monsieur Lucas j'ai bien bu
votre compromission avec le parti de
Madame Le
Pen
et Monsieur
Lucas quelle que soit cette motion de
rejet plus jamais aucune de son de
morale de politique plus jamais aucune
leçon
d'humanisme monsieur Lucas pour une
petite victoire incertaine qui va durer
quelques secondes ou le temps de ce que
dure parfois les journaux vous vous êtes
compromis et cela va vous coller
longtemps au basque à mon
avis vous avez joué la rétention des
mineurs sur un coup politique parce que
vous avez poussé le Toupé et le paradoxe
à réclamer la fin de la rétention des
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
sans jamais pouvoir se dire que vous
pourriez faire la loi et changer la vie
des gens vous êtes finalement assez bas
et je le regrette
profondément
[Applaudissements]
finalement monsieur Lucas je vous
comprends je vous comprends parce que
votre vision l'immigration en effet n'a
rien à voir avec celle que porte la
majorité je vous comprends parce que
vous avez finalement regretté tous les
gouvernements que vous avez soutenu
lorsque vous étiz socialiste lorsque
vous étiez écologiste lorsque vous étiez
en tout cas en responsabilité qui n'ont
jamais fait ce que fera cette majorité
d'une manière ou d'unut a qui n'ont
jamais été en responsabilité et qui
considère regardez autour de vous tous
les pays où les veres gouvernent
regardez en Allemagne tous les pays où
les vergom il sont en responsabilité la
vérité c'est que dans l'opposition on
fait parfois n'importe quoi en
responsabilité on répond aux besoins des
peuples voilà ce que nous faisons nous
en
responsabilité alors finalement j'en
vous entends monsieur Luc vous demandz
le rejet pas le rejet du texte le rejet
du débat l'Assemblée
nationale l'Assemblée nationale ne
pourrait pas
débattre ne pourrait pas débattre ici et
maintenant de toutes les mesures que je
vous ai griné des 2600 amendements
proposés par les
parlementaires mais alors pourquoi
passer une semaine en commission
monsieur
Lucas pourquoi ne pas évoquer tous
ensemble l'absence de votre groupe
politique et ceux de l'opposition pour
rejeter ce qu'a très bien dit le
président de la commission des lois en
commission peut-être parce que les
médias n'étaient pas aussi présent et
j'ai peur que votre opposition ne soit
médiatique et pas sur le fond de ce qui
intéresse les
Français la vérité mesdames et messieurs
les députés c'est qu'il y a un moment et
je suis parlementaire comme vous élu
dans une des circonscriptions de France
il y a un moment où lorsque des Français
se déplacent un dimanche pour mettre
votre bulletin votre nom dans une urne
il y a une responsabilité une fois deux
fois trois fois pendant un mandat où on
doit répondre à l'interrogation des
Français on doit répondre à la demande
d'exigence et de discussion on doit être
à la hauteur de la fonction et on doit
être au moment où les électeurs ont
besoin de débat et de désaccord moi
monsieur Lucas moi Madame Le Pen moi
monsieur marlex moi monsieur chassigne
moi Madame Panau je n'ai pas peur du
débat et je le souhaite et je le
souhaite j'ai oublié monsieur valallot
je m'en excuse bien volontiers mais je
l'avais confondu dans le Grand Tout de
la
nuupesse je n'ai pas peur du débat parce
que vous savez
il y a des millions de Français qui
regardent les débats que nous
avons des millions et des millions qui
vont voir les députés du rassemblement
national et certains députés des
républicains voter avec Monsieur Lucas
qui veut la régularisation de tous les
sans
papiier a
up les Français doivent comprendre
qu'une partie de la droite va voter ave
laupes qui décide désormais hors du
champ
[Applaudissements]
républicain et qu'il refuse et qu'il
refuse et qu'il refuse la main tendue du
gouvernement s'il vous
plaît mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous vous proposons de
débattre nous vous proposons de montrer
ce qui est digne en politique c'estàdire
des
désaccords nous vous montront la
possibilité de
compromis et le gouvernement arrive avec
l'idée qu'il pourrait trouver ce
compromis prouver de longues semaines de
discussion siéger le soir siéger la nuit
siéger le
weekend et avoir la possibilité enfin de
changer la vie des
Français avoir la possibilité d'
policiers nos gendarmes et nos
magistrats avoir la la possibilité de
dire que oui la politique peut des
choses alors on peut dire que c'est trop
dur on peut dire que c'est difficile on
peut dire que c'est impossible moi je
vois surtout la volonté de ne pas
discuter et de ne pas serrer la main
tendue alors
oui les mêmes qui attaent la PR ministre
sur les 4 3 en veulent un
eux-mêmes les mêmes qui veulent le débat
tous les jours ne veulent pas quand on
le propose les mêmes qui disent que le
débat doit se faire sans le
rassemblement national leur fait les
yeux
doux
[Applaudissements]
finalement le gouvernement et la
majorité est clair nous sommes ouverts
au débat nous sommes ouverts au
compromis nous sommes ouverts à la
discussion mais il est vrai que pour
discuter pour faire avancer les Français
il faut être au moins deux je vous
remerci monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup nous allons
entamer les explications de vote sur la
motion 2 minutes par orateur le premier
à s'exprimer sera le président
marcangelli pour le groupe
horizon merci merci madame la
Présidente mes chers
collègues cette motion rime avec
irresponsabilité
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverait la représ représentation
nationale d'un débat qui quel qu'en soit
l'issue est indispensable et souhaité
par les
Français responsabilité car son adoption
priverait l'état de nouveaux moyens pour
choisir qui est en droit de séjourner
sur notre territoire et à quelles
conditions
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverait la justice de la possibilité
de prendre toutes les mesures utiles à
la préservation de l'ordre public
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverit notre diplomatie de nouveaux
moyens pour contraindre les États peu
coopératifs à délivrer laisser passer
consulair sesâmes indispensables à les
exécutions réelles des ocutes
irresponsabilité enfin car s'il fallait
le rappeler nous sommes les
représentants du peuple or selon les
derniers sondages ce sont 86 % des
Français qui sont favorables à
l'expulsion des délinquants étrangers à
l'issue de leur peine de prison ce sont
80 % d'entre eux qui veulent limiter la
délivrance de visas au pays qui ne
récupèrent pas leur ressortissant
faisant l'objet
d'qtf je le dis clairement mes chers
collègues il en va de de chaque groupe
de cette hémicycle pour que ce débat ait
lieu le groupe horizon et apparenté
votera contre cette motion de rejet
préalable car l'inverse reviendrait à la
raison d'être de notre mandat
débattre je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente châelin pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre collèg monsieur le ministre
votre communication ce weekend é copie
d'un tracte de l'extrême droite votre
texte reprend les obsessions
identitaires de l'extrême droite et ce
faisant il affaiblit notre cohésion et
qu'on revient à l'intérêt général vous
pouvez nous calomnier mais les
écologistes ont toujours été droits
debout et ferme face à l'extrême droite
pendant que votre majorité était
silencieuse alors qu'il préféraent leur
mensonge ce texte monsieur le ministre
est une compilation il est une
compilation de petits arrangements il a
à la fois le paroxisme et la débat le D
en même temps il reprend les mots de
l'extrême droite il reprend ses
propositions tout en laissant quelques
miettes aux humanistes de votre majorité
le compromis exigeant il se cherche et
se trouve grâce aux discussions
transparentes où chacun fait valoir son
point de vue et où on chemine ensemble
vers une production commune c'est tout
l'inverse de vos méthodes monsieur le
ministre vous avez fait tantôt du
marchandage tantôt de la flatterie et ce
weekend de la manipulation votez cette
motion de rejet c'est affirmé qu'on a
chte pas une majorité avec des
mesurettes chers collègues de la
majorité je le sais vous êtes Loyau
président de la République vous êtes
Loyau à votre groupe et c'est tout à
votre honneur mais cette loyauté
s'arrête là où débute le caractère
personnel du vote il n'existe dans notre
République aucun mandat apératif ainsi
la loyauté n'est pas la soumission elle
n'est pas la soumission aux intérêts aux
ambitions présidentielles d'un ministre
elle n'est pas la soumission à un texte
qui joue les amalgames és pas à tomber
dans les travers populistes elle n'est
pas la soumission à un texte où votre
voix a été réprimée ou même l'évidence
du retour de la pleine régulation
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier n'a pas été retenu et si malgré
vos convictions monessieur madame de la
majorité vous empêchez le vote de cette
motion rejet vous serez responsable pour
les débats qui s'en suivent vous serez
responsable d'avoir transformé notre
assemblée en chambre des C des délires
du rassemblement national quand les
conditions ne soi pas réun oui on refuse
le débat je vous remercie madame la
Présidente la parole est à Madame Elsa
Fillon pour le groupe
GDR merci madame la Présidente nous ne
voulons pas d'eè loi sur l'immigration
qui s'inscrive dans une logique
répressive et
sécuritaire nous ne voulons pas qu'à
l'image des débats au Sénat et en
commission des lois l'Assemblée
nationale puisse être la caisse de
résonance de propos abjects aineux
xénophobe essentialisant à l'encontre
des
étrangers nous ne voulons pas d'une loi
qui attaque notre cohésion sociale en
pointant l'étranger comme suspect comme
fraudeur comme
délinquant la menace dans notre pays ce
n'est pas l'étranger ce sont les mots de
l'extrême droite nous ne voulons pas
d'une loi pour mener monsieur le
ministre une course électorale
avec l'extrême droite en réalité vous ne
menez pas la course et vous le savez ce
que vous faites c'est que vous validez
leur thèse et que vous leur donnez le
point nous ne voulons pas d'une loi qui
nourrit les fantasmes alimente les peur
parce que nous savons que ces discours
abject ces discours haineux les
alimentent dans notre pays et aliment la
violence raciste à l'œuvre déjà dans
certaines villes de notre
pays
et surtout nous ne voulons pas d'une loi
qui tourne le dos à notre ambition
d'accueil et
d'hospitalité l'immigration comme
l'hospitalité sont le fruit de notre
histoire il fonde aussi notre État de
droit nous ne voulons pas d'une loi qui
pointe
unresonsable l'étranger alors même que
la fermeture des hôpitaux le manque de
profs dans nos écoles ils ne sont pas le
fruit d'une arrivée des étrangers ils
sont le fruit de vos choix
politiques nous nous voulons des
dispositions d'accueil parce que nous
savons que l'accueil c'est la solution
pour inclure et autonomiser et il n'y a
rien là-dessus dans votre loi à part
quelques miettes laissé au gré des
discussions au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale oui nous voulons une
régularisation de tous les
travailleurs merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Estelle yousoufa
pour le groupe lot merci Mame la
présidente le groupe lot tient à ce que
notre assemblée examine et débat du
projet de loi immigration et intégration
parce que le pays le demande notre pays
qui oublie souvent que mayott frontière
sudeuropéenne subit une crise migratoire
hors norme chaque jour environ 100
migrants arrivent illégalement à Mayotte
un habitant sur deux est étranger à
Mayotte la plupart en situation
irrégulière le fic humain l'économie
illégale le vol des terres des biens les
violences quotidiennes font basculer
maottes dans l'anarchie nous maorè
sommes dépossédé des services publics
monopolisés par les étrangers toujours
plus nombreux toujours en grande
détresse alors que Mayotte est pauvre
les Maoris très modestes nous sommes
disqualifiés par le plus grand dénuement
des milliers de Comoriens de malgaches
et d'Africains qui afflu pour réclamer
logement asile scolarisation et stin
gratuit alors que Mayotte est est un
désert sanitaire sans ame alors qu'un
patient sur deux est étranger dans notre
seul hôpital Mayotte est un désert
scolaire avec des écoles sans cantine
qui tournent en rotation pour accueillir
80 % d'étrangers sur ces bancs la
circulaire tobira instituant la
solidarité nationale pour prendre en
char les mineurs isolés n'existe pas à
Mayotte des milliers de jeunes migrants
sont maintenant abandonnés à eux-mêmes
sur notre île et certains sont devenus
des bombes humaines qui sèment la
destruction et entretue avec machette et
arme à feu qui terrorise les maorés
parce que nous sommes maorés et avons
choisi de rester français la réalité des
grands principes de certains c'est que
l'accueil des étrangers n'a pas de prix
mais il a un coût et maotte le paye cher
l'état refuse tout avancé sur le
développement de nos infrastructures de
nos droits sociaux au motif de l'appel
d'air on interdit à vos compatriotes de
Mayotte de sortir de l'inégalité en
droit parce que les étrangers peuvent y
accéder en M sur notre territoire face à
cette tragédie et aux limites de la
dépense publique il faut faire des choix
parce qu'aucun système ne peut tenir
sans la contribution et l'adhésion de
tous notre souveraineté est attaquée à
Mayotte notre île est menacée
déstabilisée par l'afflux migratoire
l'Assemblée doit regarder l'immigration
en face et débattre je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chè
collègue
la parole est à Madame la Miller pour le
groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues l'immigration est un
sujet de préoccupation majeure de nos
concitoyens qui est trop souvent au tâ
de l'affrontement entre deux outrances
d'une part l'immigration zéro d'un côté
ce mythe qui nous est évidemment évoqué
très souvent par l'extrême droite de
l'autre l'ouverture total des frontières
complètement irresponsable pourtant
pourtant ce sujet appelle de notre part
une grande responsabilité et
malheureusement ces deux outrances nous
privent finalement d'une parole qui soit
responsable maîtrisée mesuré et apaiser
sur un sujet aussi complexe car ce qui
est en cause mes chers collègues c'est
la cohésion et c'est l'équilibre de
notre société ce qui est en cause c'est
notre capacité à garder notre tradition
d'accueil tout en préservant notre
identité et notre modèle d'intégration
républicain alors aujourd'hui un certain
nombre d'entre vous chers collègues vous
nous proposez de rejeter ce texte au
préalable sans même l'étudier alors que
ce sujet fait partie des sujets alors
que ça fait partie des sujets de
préoccupation principaux des Français
vous nous proposez sérieusement cet
après-midi de purement et simplement
l'éluder alors que la raison d'être de
notre institution parlementaire c'est de
permettre la confrontation des idées
politiques vous souhaitez empêcher le
débat de ce qui représente un des plus
grands défis de notre
siècle chers collègues si vous voteter
cette motion de rejet ça signifie que
vous rejetez toutes les mesures qui
permettront demain une meilleure
intégration par le travail et par la
langue si vous rejetez ce texte les
Français sauront que vous refusez de
discuter des mesures qui visent à lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
particulièrement en criminalisant les
passeurs et en luttant contre les
marchands de sommeil si vous votez cette
motion nous ne pourrons pas inscrire
dans la loi l'interdiction dans les des
mineurs dans les cras avec cette motion
vous expliquerez aussi aux français
qu'on ne se donne pas les moyens
d'expulser les étrangés délinquants
dangereux pour la société française
chers collègues entendez les Français
qui sont équeurés par les jeux
politiciens soyez à nos côtés pour
redorer le blason de notre assemblée en
bâtissant un texte utile et efficace
soyez responsable et écartez cette
motion de Roget merci merci
[Musique]
beaucoup je vous indique que sur le vote
de la motion de rejet préalable je suis
saisie par le groupe la France insoumise
et par le groupe égologiste d'une
demande de scrutin public le scrutin
public est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée
nationale
pour une fois il y aura pas le Brouis
des députés qui arrivent ils sont déjà
tous dans l'hémicycle la parole est à
Madame edvig Diaz pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
depuis plusieurs jours vous courez les
plateaux télé vous enchaînez les tweets
les mails et vous osez venir à la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale pour
nous dire honte à ceux qui ne veulent
pas débattre monsieur le ministre
provocations au-delà de faire éclater au
grand jour les divergences qui
fracturent votre majorité et votre
fébrilité sont indécentes elles sont
indécentes parce que quand on appartient
à un gouvernement à ce point adepte des
493 on ne vient pas donner des leçons de
démocratie
elles sont indécente car quand on a
votre bilan 120 attaques au couteau par
jour un taux d'exécution des des qtf qui
n'atteint même pas les 7 % des
subventions aux associations
immigrationnistes qui frollent le
milliard d'euros entre 600000 et 9
100000 clandestins qui vivent sur notre
sol et plus de 400000 étrangers légaux
qui entrent en France chaque année on ne
vient pas donner des leçons en matière
de protection des
Français enfin vos provocations sont
indécentes parce que mensongèr en effet
rien ne vous ooublige à présenter une
loi qui permettrait d'expulser quelques
étrangers par mois mais qui en même
temps en ferait rentrer de très très
nombreux vous pouvez tout à fait
présenter des lois visant uniquement à
expulser plus facilement les délinquants
et étranger alors pourquoi ne le
faites-vous pas pourquoi ne mettez-vous
pas à l'ordre du jour la proposition de
loi de Marine Le Pen visant à combattre
l'idéologie
islamiste pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
a-t-il refusé la tenue d'un référendum
sur l'immigration comme 75 % des
Français le réclament et comme Marine Le
Pen le défend depuis des
années monsieur le ministre votre texte
est invotable pour les députés d'n car
il va à l'encontre des attentes des Fran
qui sont 65% à vouloir supprimer le
droit du sol 75 % à vouloir supprimer
laame 71 % à juger que l'immigration
tire vers à la baisse les salaires
monsieur le ministre vous savez très
bien que voter la motion de rejet d'un
autre groupe politique ne signifie pas
valider sa vision politique tout le
monde sait que le rassemblement national
combat avec détermination la vision sans
frontiériste et immigrationniste de la
nupes ceci étant rappelé parce que votre
loi va aggraver la situation mratoire de
notre pays N est écoulé merci
beaucoup la
parole la parole est à Monsieur Thomas
port pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre collègue un
Français sur 3 ne mange pas à sa fin un
français sur qu a déjà renoncé à se
soigner pour des raisons financière 3000
enfants dorment chaque nuit à la rue
d'un are pays et la planète brûle voilà
les urgences qui devrai nous occuper
monsieur le
ministre au lieu de ça vous faites le
choix de viser l'étranger pour éviter de
regarder en face le bilan de vos
politiques antisociales et écciidère
vous présentez aujourd'hui une nouvelle
loi pour contrôler l'immigration
monsieur le ministre la 117e depuis 1945
la 30e depuis 1980 la 4e sous le règne
de la macronie une loi CS construite par
ministre d'extrême droite une loi
rédigée autour de la théorie du grand
emplacement théorie raciste et
complotiste utilisée par l'extrême
droite pour commettre des turies de
masse monsieur le ministre nous le
répéterons à chaque fois il n'y a pas de
vague migratoire incontrôlé en France il
y a une crise de
l'accueil pendant quatre décennies des
politiques racistes régressif et
xénophobes se sont succédés produisant
les mêmes effets dévastateurs monsieur
le ministre
en 8 ans 1700 km de frontière
supplémentaires ont été dressés dans
l'Union européenne pour quel résultat
monsieur le ministre une hausse des prix
sur le marché des passages et des m
transformé en tombeau de l'humanité vos
politiques migratoires c'est des morts
en
Méditerranée la politique des barbelé de
l'Europe forteresse est une impasse
monsieur le ministre personne ne quitte
son pays pour le plaisir l'exil est
toujours une
souffrance je le dis à nos compatriotes
qui nous écoute aujourd'hui tirez le
droit des étrangers vers le bas ne Vater
vos droits ne tombez pas dans le pièce
de la division du ministre de
l'Intérieur enfin monsieur le ministre
se préoccuper des questions migratoires
c'est s'attaquer aux causes réelles des
migration les interventions
impérialistes le capitalisme l'inaction
climatique qui force des millions de
personnes à l'exil c'est pourquoi nous
voterons en faveur de cette motion de
rejet vre texte et quitte le
ministère je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur le
Président marlex pour le groupe les
républicain merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre depuis 18 mois
personne ne peut contester que les
députés des républicain aucun de vos
collègues ne peut contester que nous
sommes allés dans le sens de l'intérêt
général en votant les textes à chaque
fois qu'il nous paraissait nécessaire et
utile au pays pour ce projet de loi
immigration nous avons travaillé main
dans la main avec nos collègue sénateur
h pour proposer aux Français le
changement radical qu'ils attendent en
matière d'immigration malheureusement
votre gouvernement a laissé piétiner en
commission des lois le texte issu du
Sénat le texte de fermeté issue du Sénat
ici même la semaine dernière votre
gouvernement a refusé à balayer d'un
revers de la main la proposition de
réarmement juridique de notre pays
proposé par Eric STI à travers une
modification de la Constitution par mich
Tabar à travers la dénonciation de
l'accord de
1968 les Français attend changement
attendent un changement radical mais le
texte sorti de la commission des lois
est une fausse promesse pire monsieur le
ministre pire ce texte permettra un
droit à la régularisation et entraînera
des régularisations massives ça nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter dans l'intérêt de
notre pays alors oui monsieur le
ministre le débat doit poursuivre il
doit se poursuivre mais sur la base du
texte de fermeté proposé par le Sénat
c'est le sens de la motion de rejet que
nous
soutiendrons je vous remercie monsieur
le
Président la parole est à Monsieur Erwan
balanan pour le groupe
démocrate merci merci madame la
Présidente un peu de silence s'il vous
plaît monsieur Lucas je vous a écouté
non non s'il vous plaît attendez
monsieur balanan un peu de silence il
nous reste deux orateurs donc monsieur
balanan pour le groupe démocrate et vous
l'écoutez allez-y monsieur Lucas je vous
ai écouté avec intérêt comme on vous
avait écouté avec intérêt en commission
en commission nous avons travaillé
longuement et vous avez reconnu
l'intérêt de ce travail donc j'avoue
aujourd'hui ne pas comprendre pourquoi
tout d'un coup au milieu du gay vous
décidez d'arrêter de travailler décidez
tout simplement de faire ce qui fait
notre crédibilité notre responsabilité
travailler au service des Français
messieurs et mesdames à ma gauche à la
droite de cet hémicycle j'ai du mal à
vous comprendre également depuis des
mois et des mois vous ne parlez que
d'immigration depuis des mois et des
mois vous ne faites de ce sujet que le
point sur le qu'il faut que vous
traitiez c'est votre seul et unique bule
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons pour
travailler et puis devant l'obstacle
vous fuyez devant l'obstacle vous
arrêtez le combat j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas c'est pas très digne et
franchement les Français ne le
comprendront pas
messieurs et madames les républicains
monsieur marlex je vous ai entendu je
vous rappelle que pendant les la
Commission on a eu un gros travail un
travail où vous étiez invité on vous y a
pas
vu pour finir je me retourne je me
retourne sur le côté gauche de cet
hémicycle vous PLT pour dire à ceux qui
hésiterai encore une motion de rejet je
vous le dis c'est le texte du Sénat qui
retournerait en CMP toutes les avancées
que nous avons eu qui qui disparaîtrai
le détricotage total de notre travail en
commission la fin de la rétention des
mineurs dans les centres de rétention et
dans l' lieu de
rétention latention que l'on aurait pour
un certain nombre de personnes qui
travaillent en France et qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas des papiers c'est ça que nous
détirons avec cette motion de rejet et
pour le débat démocratique évidemment le
groupe démocrate votera contre cette
motion de rejet je vous remercie
monsieur monsieur le député et pour
terminer la parole est à Monsieur arvé
Solignac pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente à
l'évidence ce texte ne contente pas
grand monde il mécontente ceux qui ont
reçu des gages au Sénat et je peux
comprendre que le président du groupe LR
qui voulait durcir le texte à
l'Assemblée se sente totalement floué
après le passage en commission il
mécontente surtout ceux à qui monsieur
le ministre vous aviez promis un texte
d'intégration alors que en réalité c'est
un énième texte de posture dont on peut
déjà vous prédire
l'inefficacité on acccueillera pas mieux
on inégrera pas mieux on ne reconduira
pas mieux on naméliorera pas la jungle
procédurale du droit des étrangers
depuis des mois vous tirez des bords
entre les attentes divergentes de la
macronie les ex les exigences folles de
la droite et les incantations de
l'extrême droite vous êtes égaré dans ce
triangle des Bermudes à telle enseigne
que le texte que vous avez présenté au
français il y a 1 an n'a rien à voir
avec le texte sorti du Sénat qui
lui-même n'a rien à voir avec le texte
sorti de la commission des lois quand un
ministre a perdu sa boussole
républicaine la seule urgence c'est
d'arrêter sa course
folle comprenez que les lois et les
décrets ne sont que des bouts de papier
insignifiants quand on est guidé par un
instinct de survie croire en la
dissuasion migratoire relève du myth que
croire en l'appel d'air ce texte n'est
qu'un mensonge au français auquel on
tente de faire croire que le code pénal
pourrait être l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
politique migratoire on vous a enjoint
d'accompagner d'intégrer d'accueillir
parce que nous savons que c'est un
investissement utile pour préparer la
France de demain en vain votre crédo
exclusif c'est contrôler dissuader punir
vous voulez de l'ordre vous aurez
confusion et pagaille vous voulez de
l'efficacité vous aurez le bourbier des
contentieux vous voulez de la sécurité
vous n'aurez que des peurs qui sont
sources de toutes les insécurités parce
que ce texte est porteur de désordre
plus grand que ce que vous prétendez
combattre nous voterons pour cette
motion de rejet je vous
remercie alors mes chers collègues nous
allons maintenant procéder au scrutin je
vous demande de bien vouloir regagner
vos places je mets au voix la motion de
rejet Pr
le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
548 exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 270
contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté en conséence loi est
rejeté prochaine séance demain à 9h
question orale sans débat la séance est
levée